لذلك نبدأ في تقديم الغداء في الساعة 12:30 ، والإقامة
في خدمة وجبة واحدة على الأقل ، من
الجيد أن أراك.
بعد الآن
ننسى كم نحن متشابهون
وكم الجمال هناك نصنف هؤلاء
الناس على أنهم بلا مأوى
ونضعهم في فئة وهم
يزعجوننا وأنت تعلم أن الشوارع
خطرة وهم هم لكنهم
هم  هل أنا مملوء
بالأمل والذهول تمامًا كما كنت أنا
وأنت ، كما تعلمون ، لقد
حدثت أشياء مروعة وعندما نستمع إلى
الموسيقى وعندما نقوم بالفن ، فإنها
تنقر على هذا النقاء عندما نرى جوقة
مكونة من المشردين  الناس وسكان الحي
ينهون أغنية تحصل على
قاع عاطفي وهي وضع الإبرة
في ذراعي كل يوم في
الشوارع الذين يعيشون داخل الأدغال إذا كنت
محظوظًا
لأنك تطعم مجتمعًا هنا
وأنت تسلي المجتمع
وأنت '  إعادة إظهار الحب والرحمة و
هذا شيء أوضحت لي أنه
بالنسبة لي بالتأكيد علمتني كيف
أكون كذلك